salmon sushi isn't Japanese it's
Norwegian huh
okay here's the story until about 1995
raw salmon was not consumed in Japan and
this was for one big reason Pacific
salmon has parasites oh so no salmon
sushi sashimi no spicy salmon nothing
what no one but obviously that all
changed thanks in part to this guy yes
hi my name is be unethical
Norway had a problem they had a lot of
salmon and too small a market looking
east they set their sights on Japan a
country that loves raw fish so much it's
willing to pay five times the price yes
for sushi-grade so more we formed a
committee and hired one from 1986 to
1991 I worked for cocaine
Jinnah their job was to convince
Japanese consumers that Atlantic salmon
was safe to consume raw and this was
hard just take for example pork if some
guy from Norway came here and said here
are pork meat raw it's safe it's really
yummy we'd be like man you're crazy
it was basically a matter of perception
so we had to change the whole country
number Buuren and his team got to work
they made the first ever salmon rolls
and serve them to businessmen in Japan
which they didn't like for a long time
it took actually ten years okay I get
the proper breakthrough in the market so
there it is salmon sushi didn't exist
before 1995 Buuren on behalf of the
world we thank you